President Trump going after Democrats at
his rally after they announced two
articles of impeachment the house will
be holding a markup tonight on those
charges first abuse of power
second obstruction of Congress and it
could be approved for a full house vote
and by next week here's the president
here are the facts on shifty shift this
honest guy makes up by staffers
he said the president of Ukraine
repeatedly declared that there was no
pressure but he didn't want to say that
we said say it say it you crooked
bastard saying remember bribery and this
and that occur where are they they send
these two things that not even a crime
this is the lightest weakest impeachment
fizz's impeachment light and another
Democrat says the president could be
impeached again if the current effort
fails even though we're impeaching him -
you know now there's still a number of
court cases there's a ton of information
that could come forward for example we
could get his bank records and found and
find out that he's owned a hundred
percent by the Russians so Dana house
impeachment committee will begin tonight
taking a look at the articles of
impeachment it they could resume again
tomorrow morning mm-hmm what is it what
will happen there it's gonna be pretty
boring a markup of a hearing is actually
very boring way and the thing is it's
like we keep saying it's like we know
the outcome we've skipped ahead we know
how this is going to end we don't
exactly all the twists and turns and how
long the Senate trial will be but we
know what it what it will look like but
it feels like that word the Road Runner
and we're watching the wily coyote just
walk right off the cliff like oh wow
sorry wow splat and that's splat what
you're seeing in terms of the polls and
and the Republicans haven't changed
Minds either right so it's completely
static in the last few months in fact
the last three years except for in some
of the battleground states where the
president starts to do a little bit
better maybe the Democrats think they
can get this done and
make up for lost time but I don't know
what they're doing Jesse you're a master
of rhetoric and I why did I say that I
just think it's funny when you give them
a little bit of a boost you know you
know have mom text and I try to just
give him encouragement like a mother
so impeachment light right
sleepy Joe crooked bastard for Shiff
he's just going I mean he's punching me
Mike what mini my teammate playing all
the hits one and they're working and you
guys don't have anybody on your side
playing a tune at all it's like a record
scratch today Anna was right it's boring
impeachment light is a great way to
describe it
have you guys noticed this doesn't even
seem like a real impeachment I mean it's
like a preseason game like do you'll
watch it but it doesn't really count
right it's never going anywhere it's not
going on the record
this dies in the center what it's right
other good players are in you know what
it's like it's like when you go to
Universal Studios and they do the movie
like they do ghostbusters but it's all
the really bad summer stock actors these
aren't even really like serious articles
it's being led by shift I mean a year
ago shift said the dossier had nothing
to do with the FISA warrant and now a
year later it had everything to do with
it and we're just supposed to go along
with this guy and believe everything he
says about the whistleblower and Ukraine
all over again it's enough Juan I mean I
don't even have anything else to say
about I don't believe that
sir Frederic that was very good good but
Greg so from my perspective I think well
he engaged in this rhetoric and it makes
all the Republican just line up and say
nothing here oh I'm intellectually tired
I'm bored of this story and they just
say you know what let's move on and oh
there's a conspiracy about five it's
just to me like wow how do people close
their eyes but I don't know what you're
talking about
cuz he's right it was I'm the fight it's
all falling apart impeachment is helping
him in battleground states this always
happens there's always an overcorrection
when there's overreach and I think
that's why they got to keep trying to
impeach him just try to come up with
another crime and then fill in the
blanks like it's a coloring book cuz it
always it helps them because people are
like going like this is a bunch of BS
what a waste of time they actually have
the new Paul Juan quinnipiac Paul have
you want to show the audience a longtime
national poll I'll just take it from
here we thought you were done talking
about he's a master of hosting they're
largely static but okay before you're
right he's gonna win it is landslide if
you keep at this one funny they're
changing I would say the minds of
independents who don't like this they're
changing the minds of Democrats in
congressional districts who that Trump
one Democrats who are now worried about
voting for impeachment and also I saw
today that there may be Democrat
senators who are thinking about voting
against are they will Beach men exactly
so this is a lose-lose for the Democrats
from beginning and yeah because
McConnell's job is to reserve the
majority in the Senate and Schumer's job
is to try to win back the majority in
the Senate and if you look at the states
where they're trying to win like Arizona
rose in peach we're gonna go over there
well I tell you what I heard from
Charles Schumer today I read that mr.
Schumer said this is a strong case okay
for conviction and I note that Democrat
the Democratic base as as we've heard
just now and you saw the poll that the
master host put up that in fact the
Democrats support for this has not
weighed it's still there
defendants that went up eight points you
said
kind of like a feeling of the Charlie
Brown getting trying to kick the ball
because I'm you could see it on Twitter
people their hopes are not as high as
they used to be they're just like maybe
this will come but they know they've
been screwed well and so much of this
has been you know what Adam shifts
that's what President Trump says the
media this week with the FISA stuff in
the IG report say the President Trump is
lying about all this stuff but Adam
Schiff actually has far less credibility
when it comes to this issue the
President Trump does boy if the IG
report had been you know like good news
for Trump imagine it was